Every time you reset to smell
Jessica's hair every time you relived a
satisfying fart. That's how many Mortys
you've incinerated you greedy
little junky. God even those times when
I...Especially those times.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Rick and Morty season 4
episode 8 video got super dark this week
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a Rick and Morty merch giveaway -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet we'll do top 10
and Easter eggs as we go along
starting with number 10 the title of the
episode the vat of acid episode there
were a lot of unique things about this
episode and one of them was the fact
that they actually had the title on the
title screen usually it's just the Rick
and Morty logo the title of the episode
is a reference to a couple of things
obviously the vat Abbasid trick that
Rick tries to pull which Morty hates
until Rick engineers an entire episode
around teaching him a lesson that it was
a good bit one of the funnier things is
the fact that there is a moral lesson
that Morty learns during the episode but
then Rick tells him that he's completely
wrong and thinking that that was the
point of the episode learning about
consequences
Rick's real lesson was just that all of
his ideas are always good there are no
bad ideas Morty it's all about execution
as he says but the vat of acid title is
also just a reference to the classic
trope those writers say to 80s TV and
movies where villains kept getting
dumped in vats of acid or toxic waste
so when Rick and Morty fall into the VAT
of green acid yes it is a reference to
Batman under the Red Hood the origin
story of the Joker in the 1989 Michael
Keaton Batman movie the outside of the
chemical factory that they fly to is
meant to be a little Easter Egg for ace
chemicals so if you felt like a lot of
Batman stuff was happening in this
opening scene you are correct when Rick
tries to impress Morty with the ships
auto parking function that's just a joke
about Tesla's ability to auto park and
unpark themselves we never really
learned the true purpose of the crystals
other than Rick just needs them in order
to make other things but they bring back
the multiple arms bit from episode six
only this time Rick either already drank
that blue fluid or didn't need to drink
it in order to grow that extra arm the
number nine the whole point of this part
of the episode with them
the bid on and then getting stuck in the
vat of acid with the mobsters trying to
talk through their existential crisis
and debate the science of acid is mostly
the writers seeing if they can construct
an entire episode around a vat of acid
trope that they're trying to make fun of
the dynamic between Rick and Morty is
also a little different in this episode
because normally Rick calls out tropes
when he sees them so under normal
circumstances he'd be the one making fun
of the vat of acid idea there are a
couple times in the episode where Rick
contradicts himself I'm not sure if
that's because they wrote the episodes
in a weird way or if the writers
genuinely made a mistake but Morty loses
his patience again and blows the bit so
that they can leave but then number
eight Rick breaks the fourth wall a
couple times referencing several
previous episodes of the show he calls
out the events of pickle Rick during
season 3 and then using a morty episode
as an example of how his ideas are bad
he makes fun of claw and hoarder from
season four the reason he says pickle
Rick was a cooler episode was because
the show actually in real life won an
Emmy Award for that when he's still
making fun of Morty and makes the game
of Thrones joke he talks about them
getting in on the fever right is it Pete
that's because the episode aired after
Game of Thrones had ended in the fans
that got really pissed off at the ending
of Game of Thrones the claw and horror
episode even actually cast liam
Cunningham sir Davos himself from Game
of Thrones as the voice of Morty's
dragon he goes pretty deep with his
zingers referencing beatniks and
Bukowski just as to sort of follow up to
Morty's joke about English earlier in
the episode then this whole bit about
Morty constantly pitching Rick ideas
that he hates feels like the writers
making fun of the fandom again like
Morty's millions of random ideas that
could be bad could be good represent all
the things that the fans asked dan and
Justin to do four episodes the number
seven the episode turns into a
combination of that Adam Sandler movie
click with the remote that he used to
control time the remote itself even
looks like the remote from click in a
bunch of time loop movies a really good
example would be like edge of tomorrow
where his time line resets to a save
point every single time he dies but he
remembers everything so even though Rick
resets everything at the end of the
episode all the alternate realities
Morty remembers all them at the end of
the episode so he's going to go forward
remembering all those things that he did
later we find out that when Morty is
trying to bait Rick into creating the
device Rick doesn't actually cave in he
just allows Morty to think that he
tricked him into making the device when
Rick really made it in service of the
i-told-you-so quote-unquote moment
except the whole I told you so of the
episode is actually about the vat of
acid being a good bit not any kind of
morality lesson like Morty mistakenly
thinks he references an episode of
Futurama where they did this exact same
thing the episode was season 7 episode
26 titled meanwhile and it was fry who
kept resetting the timeline they break
the fourth wall again when Rick implies
that he's ok ripping off other TV shows
episodes but one of the errors in his
rant you probably noticed is when Rick
says he doesn't do time-travel that was
only true up to season 4 episode 5 with
the Terminator snakes that whole episode
was about time travel I don't know if
this is the writers making an error or
if they wrote the episode before they
wrote episode 5 of their production
cycle or just worked out weird with the
time-travel episode coming in before
this episode but the whole idea of them
not doing time-travel is a reference
that goes back to season 1 of the show
in the time-travel box in the garage
it's a rule in real life that Dan Harmon
created when they started this show he
said that time-travel was a concept that
just created too many problems for story
logic so he decreed that the show would
not do time-travel stories ever in the
box on the shelf was just a reference to
that like something that they would pack
up put in the Box put on a shelf and
never touch but they kind of went out
the window with season 4 episode 5 and
then at the end of the episode Rick
explains how Morty's device wasn't
actually controlling time the way Morty
thought it was it was actually shifting
him through other dimensions he calls
Morty an insult then says Bugs Bunny
created reverse psychology they just a
reference to the classic Bugs Bunny
cartoons burrito his trick Elmer Fudd by
telling him not to do things
number 6 notice Rick's canister on the
floor reads TGRI
most of you children of the 80s and 90s
remember that's a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles reference
maybe there's a missing adventure where
Rick turns Morty into a ninja turtle
with some ooze Rick actually lies to
Morty when he says he's going to kill
him because he's still breathing after
he shoots them and shifts into another
reality because remember the whole thing
here is that this
is the original Morty so he's shifting
that one into other realities and just
killing the ones that he's replacing
when he arrives it's actually a
different Rick because each of these
Rick's have vats of acid every Rick has
a vat of acid so during the episode
technically he visits hundreds of
different realities morty takes the
device and we go to school we get the
most epic backstory for mr. goldenfold
you could do a whole spin-off TV show
about the adventure that he tells in his
backstory with the Ren Faire lady in the
misadventures with the new diseases his
joke about being absent for most of the
school year is just a reference to him
not being in that many episodes this
season the kid sitting in front of Morty
is actually a parody of Justin roiland
in real life then number five they set
up the whole bit with Jessica where
Morty actually gets her to be way more
interested by pretending to not care
about her that's also a bit of a trope
of high school stories to like treat a
girl like crap and then she'll like you
way more he could always try to come
back to this reality and get with this
version of Jessica because as you see at
the end of the episode all the different
realities and things that he did one of
them he actually went on a couple of
dates with Jessica so it seemed like
they were pretty close to getting
together the song that they play over
Morty's epic montage is Eric Clapton's
it's in the way that you use it and yes
morty does a bunch of messed up stuff
thinking that he's taking it all back
with the reset button but the other
crazy thing about this part of the
episode is that dan harmon revealed when
they originally wrote and recorded the
episode with the actors the episode
itself came in five minutes short that
is crazy if you know anything about
animation because episodes are normally
only about 23 minutes long without
commercials so that's like a whole act
of the episode that they just didn't
write for this what harmon said they
wound up doing is the animation director
saved the episode because he came in
after the fact and added all those bits
with the airplane and the alive
references himself after they recorded
the episode that's why some of these
parts of the montage have no dialogue
because some of those were things that
they added after the fact to make the
episode as long as it needed to be so if
he thought it was weird that so much of
the episode in this montage didn't have
any dialogue that's why they even get a
little met again when morty uses his
device on the video game to create a
save
in real life instead of using the one
that's actually built into the game
itself that's just a bit of a reference
to the actual premise of this whole
montage number four he gets super dark
with the whole suicide-by-cop it seems
like he does it on a whim he doesn't
even think about it like it's something
he wanted to do before
yikes that is dark but that's not the
darkest part of the episode when he's
driving the car with the addict the
license plate reads TNG season 8 that's
a reference to Star Trek The Next
Generation Season 8 which isn't a real
thing in real life it's just a joke
Twitter account with parody episodes
because TNG only went to seven seasons
there's also a banner in the background
with a watch on it that reads reset
referencing Morty's device when Morty
takes the old man's wheelchair most of
you noticed there's a huge Simpsons
reference because this is the exterior
of Moe's Tavern way back in the early
seasons of Rick and Morty The Simpsons
did a special Rick and Morty intro for a
Simpsons episode porta that's because
Danny Justin are friends in real life
with The Simpsons producers so there was
a commentary episode where a bunch of
Simpsons producers came in did
commentary for Rick and Morty episode
you also notice in this Simpsons scene
in the background there's a sign that
reads poor decisions just referencing
Morty making really terrible decisions
number three they start the whole
girlfriend bit when he decides to go for
her instead of the strip club most of
you could probably tell where this was
headed in the first few moments morty
falls in love they make it seem like
it's really nice everything is going
great for him anytime things seem like
they're going great for Morty you just
wait for them to pull the rug out from
under him they break up they get back
together they come full-circle their
relationship seems like it goes on for a
long time and then after a bunch of time
goes by he and his girlfriend take a
vacation to Alaska but the plane crashes
and it turns into a parody of the movie
alive the movie is based on a book that
was written about a real-life event the
book was called alive the story of the
Andy's survivors which details a
Uruguayan rugby teams crash aboard a
Uruguayan Air Force flight 571 in the
Andes Mountains in 1972 if you haven't
seen that movie it plays out pretty much
the way you see it happened during the
Rick and Morty scenes they wind up
having to eat each other to stay alive
before they get rescued it gets super
dark
Morty even tries to kill himself he's
done that before
in the past though when they're rescued
they try to play it like he's not going to
go back he's going to keep living with his
girlfriend in this reality until of
course Jerry messes everything up
pressing the button taking him way back
to another reality they played a little
bit like a longer version of the Roy
game joke where he came out remembering
his fake life a little not quite sure
what's real and what's fake anymore when
he keeps jumping into the gorilla cage
over and over at the zoo that's a bit of
a reference to Deadpool - there was a
scene during that movie where Deadpool
is trying to kill himself where he keeps
jumping into an animal cage Morty tries
to tell Rick what he thinks the lesson
of the whole adventure was after which
Rick reveals the truth of what really
happened making it seem like Morty did
way way worse things than he thought
think about all the Morty's you killed
number two Rick references ant-man the
wasp time travel that's a joke about
Avengers endgame and Marvel using the
quantum realm to play with different
types of time travel also a bit of a
meta Easter Egg because this guy here
one of the writers of the episode was
just hired by Marvel to write their Ant
Man 3 movie which is going to come out in a
couple years
Rick references the ending of The
Prestige movie in that movie Hugh
Jackman's character made it seem like he
was performing a teleportation trick but
the real trick was that Nikola Tesla
built him a real life working teleporter
but each time what was happening is when
he would use the device it would create
a facsimile like when you send a
real-life fax so Hugh Jackman wound up
having to kill a version of himself each
time he used that device Rick makes the
Jeffrey Dahmer reference is everybody in
town shows up for Morty's blood the
reason why they all show up all the
police the special interest groups is
because Morty as Rick says didn't reset
his actions so within this reality he
did a bunch of terrible things and now
they're just coming because they're so
pissed off at him Rick shows Morty that
the whole time reset adventure was
actually just a lesson an elaborate bit
to teach him that the vat of acid is a
good bit because this vat of acid that
he has ready in their yard is the only
way to get everyone to back off and
leave him alone also if you look at some
of these signs in the background that
they're holding one says cannibalism is
a choice implying Morty did something to
piss cannibals off one says return the
whales implying Morty did something to a
bunch of whales and
of his adventures and I'm not sure what
Moscow Morty is a reference to but they
make a couple poetry references one to
Shakespeare's Merchant of Venice and
then the addict from the car earlier in
the episode tries to make another poetry
reference that's actually Alan Tudyk
coming back to do a celebrity cameo
again the number one they said up
the whole post credit scene bit with a
SWAT team officer who thinks he's immune
to acid in the Johnny Carson bit because
in this reality a bunch of things are
different that are actually good Johnny
Carson was still on TV in The Tonight
Show Ed McMahon who is also still alive
still working with him in apparently
Rick really likes their version of rocky
road here because he hates marshmallows
which Morty apparently loves so because
of the way the episode works and Morty
shifting through different realities I
think he set a record in this episode
for a number of different realities that
he visited within a single episode but
if you spotted any big easter eggs in
the episode that I didn't include in the
video just write them below in the
comments in my episode 9 trailer video
will post tomorrow leave all your Rick
and Morty video requests in the comments
below every one click here for all my
Rick and Morty episodes and click here
to learn about Marvel's brand-new Ghost
Rider project thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe I'll see
you guys tonight!